hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well in his discussion of the
cosmological ideas in the third part of
his proma to any future metaphysics
Emanuel Kant is going to consider two of
them as what he calls dynamical dynisha
and tinies and both of these have to do
with
causality which is one reason why it's
going to be dynamical as opposed to
mathematical and just to review a little
bit each of these contains a thesis a
zot and an antithesis a gag andot a
contradictory proposition and you know
ideally they both can't be true at the
same time that's the way we look at
contradictory propositions that's
actually not going to be the case for
these dynamical antinomies so the the
third first of the dynamic ones is there
are in the world causes through Freedom
as the thesis and then as the antithesis
there is no freedom but all is nature so
everything is either caused in a you
know determinant ISM or there's like
little spaces where there's some Freedom
possible within it that's one way to
interpret it the second or the of the
dynamical the fourth of the antines
proper thesis is in the series of world
causes there is some necessary being the
antithesis there is nothing necessary in
the world but in this series all is
contingent so necessity and contingency
are being opposed to each other as well
and notice it's not saying everything is
necessary it's just saying there has to
be a necessary being or everything is
contingent could be other than it is a
necessary being is one that is the way
it is of necessity including its
existence it has to exist from necessity
it must exist it couldn't not exist so
Kant is going to draw a really important
distinction here between the
mathematical antinomies and the
dynamical antinomies he tells us in the
first class of these the falsehood of
the presupposition consists in
representing in one concept something
con self-contradictory as if it were
compatible in the second we're reversing
that it's in some respects the opposite
the falsehood of the Pres position the
for zet what it is that we're we're
assuming is that what is
compatible bar what can be
unified is represented as being
contradictory V so the first kind we
were not noticing that there is a
self-contradictory concept that we're
beginning from in this case there
actually isn't a contradiction there
appears to be it's represent as such but
it isn't actually going to be
contradictory and so he's going to go on
and say
um in the first case the opposed
assertions were both false
but because of a mere
misunderstanding uh Mis forness right
both assertions which are being opposed
to each other by that misunderstanding
they can actually both be true not only
can they be true Kant is saying they are
actually true both at the same time so
how is this the case he says okay
mathematical
connection necessarily presupposes
homogenity G like AR things being of the
same kind quite literally or a similar
kind or comparable kind so it
presupposes the homogeneity of what is
connected um the dynamical one he says
doesn't require this as a matter of fact
not only doesn't it require
this the things that we're comparing
aren't of the same kind even though we
might be misled by using the same word
like cause uraka in in German so he says
the connection of cause and effect
doesn't actually require homogeneity it
can be found sometimes right when a
similar thing is the cause of an effect
so think about a mechanical process
right you got mechanisms producing
effects you know or events in other
mechanisms great that's all on the same
level but cause and effect doesn't have
to go that way it's possible for there
to be you know not similar not
equivalent types of causes and effects
so the concept of
causality doesn't require homogeneity
so what assumptions are going to make
the
contradiction unavoidable the incorrect
contradiction he says if the objects of
the world of sense are taken for things
in themselves if we assume that we're
talking about things as they are behind
the appearances when we're actually
talking about the realm or world of
appearances and then going further we
take the laws of nature and laws of
nature are ways of understanding causes
and effects right this cause leads to
this effect and it does so in in this
way if we take the laws of nature which
and remember nature for Kant includes
the phenomenal realm what it is that we
can experience if we take those laws for
the laws of things in themselves
the things in themselves can have laws
but they're not going to be the same
thing as the laws of nature so if we
make those mistakes those assumptions
we're going to wind up with these
antinomies thinking that one or the
other of them has to be true and the
other has to be false and then trying to
use reason to get our way to them and
then being quite upset when we find out
that reason can make a case for both of
them or make a Cas against either of
them at the same time so what is our way
out of this problem and I should point
out here that Kant is going to devote a
lot of discussion to the third antiny
very very little just a summary
discussion to the fourth antinomy and
perhaps what we ought to understand here
is that the solution to the third is
really providing us with almost
everything that we need just a little
bit of content missing for the fourth so
third antiny is is everything determined
or do we actually have free causes
causes that emerge from Freedom within
the The Ordering of things not things in
the world but things in a broader sense
so he starts off by saying in appearance
every effect is an event or something
that happens in time right the effect
must according to the universal law of
nature be preceded by a
determination of the
causality of its cause on which the
effect follows according to a constant
law okay so far so good so we've got
cause the cause determines the effect it
precedes the effect in time the effect
arises in time notice time right the
phenomenal world
so he goes on and he says this
determination of the cause to causal
action must likewise be something that
takes place or happens so the cause must
have beg to act um otherwise the effect
as well as the causality of the cause
would have always existed so the
determination of the cause to act must
also have originated among appearances
and must consequently just like it's its
effect be an event which means it must
have its cause so we can now get a whole
chain of causes and effects where each
member of the chain is both an effect of
preceding causes and a cause of
following effects and this all happens
in time so so far so good I think this
is pretty non-controversial this is
often how we represent causes and
effects to ourselves so where's the
problem there well it seems like natural
necessity must be the condition
According to which efficient causes are
determined so where would Freedom be it
can't arise anywhere in this long chain
of appearances that we call causes and
effects can it because if it did it
would violate this necessary law of
nature right so you know this is
happening within time natural necessity
applies to it
where do we get
freedom freedom itself counts as is a
cause if freedom is to be a property of
certain causes of appearances it must be
a faculty of starting them
spontaneously without the causality of
the cause needing to begin and hence
needing no no other ground to determine
its beginning and then he says the cause
as to its causality the cause of freedom
must not stand under time determinations
it doesn't happen within time it happens
outside of of that so it cannot be an
appearance and he says it must be
considered a thing in itself the free
cause that causes free choices actions
determinations whatever you want to call
it that then get inserted into the
phenomenal world of appearances is
happening outside of that as a thing in
itself and so he says if without
contradiction we can think of the beings
of understanding as exercising such an
influence on appearances natural
necessity will attach to all connections
of cause and effect in the sensuous
world but Freedom can be granted to the
cause which is not itself an appearance
but the ground or
Foundation of appearance right
so you know this is this is going to be
quite important and he's going to talk
about a
faculty that does this uh this this
connection he says expressed by a if you
know kant's moral philosophy you know
exactly where he's going with this you
don't need to go to uh section three of
the groundwork of the metaphysics of
morals where he's you know essentially
saying similar things to this you know
he's talking about F or reason reason
determines itself reason is a higher
faculty than the understanding or
sensibility which are connected with
this world of experience and and
structure it right reason takes us
beyond that and in this case reason can
actually yield Us free causes of
effects so he says um in so far as we
consider a Being Human Being entirely
according to this objectively
determinable reason he cannot be
considered as a being of sense rather
this property is that of a thing in
itself and we cannot comprehend the
possibility of this property I mean how
the
art uh which might never have yet taken
place should determine its activity and
could become the cause of actions whose
effect is an appearance in the sensible
world and he's going to say something
really interesting here about the
freedom I mean it sounds like well you
could push this back further and say
well you're appealing to this a so you
know reason when it's following the a is
actually being determined by that so
it's not really free now is it maybe
it's Freer when it doesn't obey the
ought and Kant says yes
both when it's obeying the a when it's
making that a its own it is acting out
of freedom and when it doesn't do that
as he says um when the action is not
performed on principles of Reason which
we call maxims it is subject to the
empirical laws of
sensibility um but in the first case you
know acting according to maxims reason
is the cause of these laws of nature
therefore free in the second the effects
follow according to Mere natural laws of
sensibility because reason doesn't
influence but reason itself is not
determined on that account by the
sensibility and is therefore also still
free so it's a free cause whether it
determines or doesn't determine if it
just lets things happen the way that
they are so he says what's the upshot of
this freedom is therefore no hindrance
to natural law in
appearances neither does this law abgate
the freedom of the Practical use of
Reason which is connected with things in
themselves as determining grounds we are
things in themselves as such determining
grounds right so you know he goes on
further but I think you get the the gist
of what he is saying here I'll just uh
remark one other thing that he says here
says we are able in rational beings or
in beings generally so far as their
quality is determined in themselves as
things in themselves to think of a fact
faculty of beginning of themselves a
series of states without falling into
contradiction with the laws of nature we
don't actually have a contradiction
there why because one of them is
happening in time within the realm of
appearances sensibility the other is
emerging into that from outside of it
now what about the fourth antinomy he
says it's solved in the same way as the
conflict of reason with itself in the
third so we can apply a similar logic he
says provided the cause in the
appearance is distinguished from the
cause of the appearences so we've got
two different things cause in the
appearance in a chain of causes and
effects right um and then we have cause
maybe we want to put a Capital C on that
that is the cause of all the
appearances um that could not itself be
an appearance that couldn't be within
that series or structure of
quality it has to be outside of time and
space and experience so he says um we
can you know reconcile these
propositions one of these is that
there's nowhere in the sensuous World a
cause according to similar laws of
causality whose existence is absolutely
necessary the other that this world is
nevertheless connected with a necessary
being as its cause so you know a
necessary being a being whose existence
is necessary a vasin in this case right
so this is signifying whatever we want
to call it you know the originator of
everything the cause Capital C you might
call this God although K's a little cagy
about that sort of thing we're going to
see this discussed a bit in the
theological idea whose discussion
immediately follows these so the these
are the dynamical as opposed to merely
mathematical antinomies of pure reason
which lead us into at least with the
third one into morals into thinking
about ourselves and as being things in
themselves and then we could think about
that other being that vasin as a thing
in itself as well but a different kind
of thing in itself a completely
necessary being both of these are
compatible with having a world in which
causal
determinism actually
holds